just getting to watch
abel firsthand you know the weekend
first of course music and
um crazy run he was on i mean still i
mean just that album i feel like it's
just
i've never seen an album with more legs
like yeah man
but he's gonna tour for that album next
year and it came out 20 nights eat like
it's crazy and honestly the album
deserves it because it's like
those are the things that inspire me
when i watch someone put together a
masterpiece like that and i got
front row you know seats to the show
like
that's that's inspiring those were some
of the moments that made me be like yo
yeah you know what i do i do love this
there's something about this that i
that like you know it's something that's
different than anything else on the
planet nothing else can make me feel
like this so
those those are the moments that started
to kind of swing me back you know i mean
yeah i mean creatively like i feel like
you're kind of a
and when i meet other belly fans it's
like we're like we're like uh
it's almost like an exclusive sneaker
club or something you know what i'm
saying like
like like if you know you know type [ __ ]
like oh you [ __ ] with belly oh [ __ ]
like yeah you know what i mean i love
that though i love that
i love that man